hi there welcome to the point in case
you don't know i like hearing stories
embed video games i liked hearing them
when i worked in gamestop i liked
hearing them when i met new people when
i moved from country to country and now
i'm really lucky that in my job I get to
hear stories about games all the time
and like favorite stories about games
are the ones about weird obscure kind of
shitty games that nobody in their right
mind should ever remember when the
history of video games is written down
it'll be full of triple-a blockbusters
minecraft call of duty world of warcraft
tomb raider and mario bros but some of
the most interesting stories in video
games come from games that nobody in
their right mind should care about games
that weren't really good but were
memorable for entirely other reasons so
today on the point we're going to talk
about one of those stories a story from
my childhood a story about a game that
in all likelihood wrote dozens of
copyright laws a story about a game that
was kind of and a story about a
game that I still own three illegal
copies of to this day ladies and
gentlemen this is the story of the great
giana sisters the point season 3 episode
11 Mario's German stepsister
okay first some context fear is 1988 in
video game consoles are going through a
bit of a revolution this was the era of
Atari spectrum Nintendo Sega Commodore
these were the real console wars not
these shitty console wars you have
nowadays where kids are complaining
about a few lines of who gives a
resolution in a game that's coming out
on three platforms on the same day now
this was the area where games only came
out on specific consoles and one
Christmas in Ireland Santa Claus brought
me my brother and my sister a joint gift
and from then on I was part of the
Commodore clan this is my Commodore
Amiga 600 it's got a sweet keyboard it
plays floppy disks and it's got one
megabyte of RAM and so for comparison
this iPhone 6 has 1024 megabytes of RAM
but this was the first console the first
computer rather than I ever owned that
was about 5 or 6 years old when we got
it and the games that I played on this
machine informed gamer I am today games
like sensible soccer cannon fodder speed
ball zoo James pond these were games it
came out on Commodore first and
eventually made their way onto other
consoles and computers and the opposite
happened to amiga owners got ports of
loads of games over the years games like
XCOM and Monkey Island came over from
the pc but there was one system that
never shared its toys a new machine that
had successfully invaded North America
from japan and was starting to sink its
teeth into the european market the
Nintendo Entertainment System had
reached European shores as of September
of 1986 and it's killer app Super Mario
Brothers had arrived the following may
this was a game that everyone was
talking about a colorful platformer with
power-ups bosses smooth animations great
soundtrack and challenging gameplay
Super Mario Bros was a 2d side-scrolling
game for the NES in which you played
mario an Italian guy who traveled
through a fantastical world each level
contained a number of coins which can be
collected for points collect 100 of
these coins and you'd also get an extra
life enemies were defeated by stomping
on their heads the game is full of
floating platforms bizarre pipes and a
castle sat at the end of each stage over
world stages were vivid and colorful
while under grant stages were mostly
dark blue the game featured memorable
5th uzak had a total of thirty-two
stages and was two player a second
player could play as Mario's brother
Luigi and it had iconic boss fights like
this battle with King Koopa the great
giana sisters was a 2d side-scrolling
game for the amiga in which you played
Tiana and italian girls who traveled
through a fantastical world each other
contained a number of dream crystals
which could be collected for points
collect 100 of these dream crystals and
you get an extra life enemies were
defeated by stomping on their heads in
floating platforms bizarre castles at
the end of each stage over all stages
were vivid and colorful while another
grand stages were mostly dark plan the
game featured naturally pin music stages
almost 2 player a second player could
play his child sister Liu area and it
had a common across sites like this
bottle with some sort of ants
spider situation the great giana sisters
was a game made by german designer
armand guess art under the studio title
time warp who wanted to make most of the
growing interest in nintendo's new
franchise and it worked this super mario
bros clone spread quickly across the
continent however almost entirely
through illegal channels the common
amiga had a horrific piracy problem that
would eventually put commodore out of
business i mean the fact that the
computer had a game copying utility
included in the box probably didn't help
i bought dozens of games for this system
but my game library was huge mostly made
up of disks my brother had copied at
various friends has but even to a market
full of pirates giana sisters was kind
of a step too far does that expectant
version was reviewed by a bunch of
magazines but never made it into store
shelves because of legal pressure the
same pressure that force Tameeka
versions off the shelves in Germany
years later Nintendo would admit they
were to blame but that didn't stop
Armand from making a sequel of sorts
gianna to arthur and maria in future
world was in development for a number of
months before time warp realized that
Nintendo would probably get involved
again so they eventually changed the
main characters into robots and renamed
as hard and heavy the giana sisters was
a product of its time I mean by any
stretch of copyright law this game was
taking the piss we're no stranger to 2d
homages to classic games now but the
giana sisters came out just a couple of
years after Super Mario Bros however it
also seems that
times a healer in 2009 and perhaps the
ballsiest move in the history of video
games publishing DDP entertainment
released the port of the original game
on the Nintendo DS so 22 years after the
original game was chased out of German
store shelves by Nintendo a better
looking carbon copy of mario bros was
now a Nintendo handheld exclusive and as
if this wasn't weird enough a
fully-fledged new giana sisters game
twisted dreams came out in 2012 and it's
probably the best game in this series so
this is a good chance we haven't heard
the end of this story just yet
you